you auditioned for Titanic or you wanted
the deposit I did and I wanted the part
the rumor is that I got the part in the
client that's false you wanted that hell
yeah and when you hear that Leonardo
DiCaprio gets that role which was so
defining for him is that defeating to
you do you start to doubt yourself as an
actor do you say why did he get it not
me or do you just kind of just accept it
accept it and move on I was already on
on to the the next do you go to the
movie to see how the actor handled it
when you when you auditioned for
something and and uh not necessarily I
don't seek it out you gotta like go
measure how they did
yeah but I'd be curious you know you
know what I mean I want to know what how
another actor handled it
or I knew it was a good actor then yeah
you know yeah uh the movie you turned
down that you regret was LA Confidential
that would be the closest one that I saw
the movie and I was like I would have
really liked to be a part of that yeah
that was a good movie yeah damn right it
was yeah so but later why'd you turn it
down
man at that time it was during the time
to kill right and time to kill just
opened now you got to understand that
the Friday before time to kill opens
I've there's a hundred scripts I'd do a
hundred of them and they're only
offering one right time to kill opens
that weekend that Monday that same
hundred scripts they're offering 99.
right so I'm going whoa three days ago I
would have done any of these and now
you're saying hey here they all are
which one do you want right I needed
more than 24 hours in a day and I didn't
know I didn't know I wasn't sure what I
wanted
foreign